I'm Rimuru Tempest,
a slime
[Music]
Well, Tempest seems to be peaceful today too.
Becoming friends with the elegant Veldora
, creating a kingdom of monsters
, fighting to protect everyone,
look at Shizuka-
san, I was able to rescue the children at 6 o'clock.
I don't care if it lasts forever I'm meeting you for the first time Jeller I'm from the Tempest Federation
, I thought it was a beaming Tempest, and
I decided to interact with the lasagna for the development of Tempest.
It's
me me
me
And I've been invited by Gazelle-sama and it's over
I'm going to save this place
That's what
I'm calling  Salon
Nice to meet you It's goodbye soon But
your city is
in the way So I decided to destroy it
I want to build a nation that can serve as a bridge between
the two worlds.Ah, the reason is that my grandmother feels like she
's in charge.I think it's too early to be victorious.
yeah yeah
[music]
our new ally Wizard Mughan
House of Tempest